with the release of 2021's eternals the
marvel superhero known as ajak will
finally be coming to the silver screen
as portrayed by salma hayek but who
exactly is ajax and why is the character
so important to the eternals this is
ajax story explained
although they haven't always been at the
forefront of most fans minds the
eternals cast a huge shadow over the
history of the marvel universe those
mutations that make the x-men so uncanny
they're tied to the eternal's origin
thanos he's involved with them too in a
roundabout way the eternals once
colonized a little place called titan
which became home to thanos centuries
later i am
inevitable
the eternals are essentially the product
of experimentation performed by an
ancient omnipotent group of super-sized
humanoids called the celestials the
celestials tinkered with humanity's
genetic code creating two offshoot races
the grotesque creatures known as the
deviants and the immortal super-powered
beings that make up the eternals despite
looking like humans the eternals are
very nearly divine in their abilities
they can control the aging process cast
illusions fly read minds and transform
matter essentially they are gods and
have often ended up becoming the source
of many of humanity's legends religions
and fables for example the eternal
cersei was immortalized as cersei and
homer's odyssey while icarus's life
inspired the ancient tale of icarus
like his fellow eternals ajak has a rich
backstory of his own however to fully
understand who he is it's important to
understand what he can do ajac is
equipped with superhuman strength for
one he can also fly at speed teleport
and do almost everything that falls
under the general category of energy
manipulation when it comes time to throw
down against the bad guys he's capable
of projecting beams of heat and
concussive energy from his eyes and
hands he is also a brilliant
archaeologist perhaps helped by the fact
that he was around for much of the
history he digs up in some of the latest
eternal stories ajac has also been shown
to have the power to change gender
although it's uncertain how much of this
constitutes a retcon uniquely ajax
possesses an uncanny ability to
communicate with the celestials this is
pretty much his signature ability when
it comes to protecting humanity as few
other eternals are able to do it and
given that the celestials have a habit
of showing up every now and again to see
if they feel like destroying the earth
it's fair to say that ajax's powers are
pretty vital to the team
ajax was born in the eternal city of
paleria located in the ural mountains to
parents named raqqar and amma his branch
of the species is sometimes referred to
as the polar eternals not much is known
about ajac prior to the celestial's
intervention in his life but it is known
that ajax and his brother arax were
active in ancient greece around 1200 bc
or the former was mistaken for the
mythical hero of the trojan war ajax
unfortunately there's very little
information about what happened to arex
after the brother's time in greece came
to an end he pops up only very rarely in
the marvel canon and the jury is out as
to whether or not he's even still alive
after greece ajax wandered the earth
making his way to places such as babylon
where he took on the deviant leader
warlord crow
after that he spent some time in the
americas where he was worshiped as a god
the aztecs paid tribute to him as
quetzalcoatl one of the wisest and most
powerful of their deities in time the
incas also came to worship ajak as teku
mozan the lord of flight and ajak wasn't
shy about using his supreme power to
advance the civilizations he favored by
1000 ad ajak was an accomplished warrior
cosmic genius and influential figure in
the progress of humanity well that would
be enough for most superheroes to hang
their hats on however ajax's greatest
feats yet would come with the return of
the celestials
unable to escape his own past ajac
crossed pass with both the celestials
and the deviants once again when the
former returned to earth on a
fact-finding mission this is because
earth wasn't the only planet the
celestials decided to experiment on the
home worlds of races such as the skrulls
and the cree got the same treatment for
example to help judge whether or not
they had been a success the celestial
subjected each race to four tests or
hosts to deem them worthy of life during
the third host ajax was living in peru
he acted as a liaison between the
celestials and humanity as well as a
go-between for the celestials and the
gods humanity had given rise to such as
zeus of the greek pantheon luckily
humanity passed the test with flying
colors and ajax decided to put his atoms
into storage until the celestials
returned
eventually the fourth host of celestials
returned to earth to see how their
experiments were faring kicking off
ajax's story in the modern marvel
universe ajak is awoken by icarus in
1976 eternals number two soon after the
celestials once again come to south
america and settle on an incan plateau
that ajax had set up for them and once
again he acts as their liaison this time
however their presence sparks
intervention from the likes of shield as
well as odin and the forces of asgard
because that's what heroes do despite
the combined efforts of all three
factions earth ends up losing the fight
against the celestials however the
battle helps the celestials realize that
humanity is worthy and therefore they
agree to let the earth off the hook most
of the important players have their
memories erased to the whole incident
and the eternals realize they needn't
worry about the celestial's
interventions anymore so it's good news
all around but it also means that ajax
is out of a job
during the fourth post event ajax
befriends a human archaeologist named dr
daniel damian after icarus brings a
brilliant doctor along to awaken ajax
the two become thick as thieves damien
even watches the fourth post event take
place from within the celestial's
impenetrable dome however he is more
interested in preserving the history of
the incas than he is in making sure
humanity passes its test
damien begins with all the makings of a
classic superhero ally but grief does
horrible things to people his daughter
margot flees the celestial city with
icarus while damian agrees to stay
behind to protect history icarus and
margot are separated and she is later
turned into a deviant and killed in an
attempt to get to icarus in the wake of
this tragedy damian seeks revenge on
celestials deviant's eternals a lot of
them part of his plan includes an
elaborate trick against the eternals and
deviants specifically he turns ajak into
a literal monster needless to say
damian's relationship with the eternal
sours and his friendship with ajax dies
a miserable death
damien's plan involves planting false
prophecies about the twin offspring of
eternals and deviants being the ones to
eventually conquer both races he then
uses advanced celestial technology to
transform ajak into a monster whose sole
purpose seems to be systematically
hunting down and killing twin siblings
on earth thus mutated ajak assists in
the kidnapping of twins donald and
deborah ritter the offspring of the
eternal athena and the deviant crow
fortunately the doctor's plan to kill
the twins in front of their parents
fails when icarus gets wise to the whole
situation and disgusted with his own
actions ajax disintegrates both himself
and damien
luckily this all happens in the world of
comic books where death is merely a
distraction ajac is eventually
resurrected in the chambers of the
eternal city of olympia by an eternal
named sprite sprite is later revealed to
be deceiving ajac in the other eternals
into helping him use the power of the
fabled dreaming celestial to overwrite
reality sprite's plot is thwarted but it
leads to an enduring rivalry between
ajac and another eternal one that would
result in his second death and
resurrection
when the dreaming celestial is awoken it
chooses the eternal makari as its
spokesperson obviously ajax's experience
in this field is extensive so he
understandably feels a little slighted
by this choice and soon grows to hate
makari he even hatches a plan to kill
him but while makari does die it doesn't
stick now at loose ends ajax decides to
travel the world and learn as much as he
can about the celestials he lives in san
francisco for a time and even becomes a
gardener this journey eventually leads
ajax to join hercules in a battle with
the scroll gods in which he squares off
with a divine scroll named kleiben it's
during this fight that ajax dies again
again this being the marvel universe
ajax's death doesn't last he returns to
earth and travels to olympia where he
lives among his fellow eternals however
all this changes the day dead celestials
reign from the sky signaling the arrival
of the dark celestials on earth that's
when the eternals learn a terrible
secret about themselves and their
existence one that leads all of them to
either turn on each other or kill
themselves of course once again they've
all been revived ajax stars as a woman
alongside makari in the 2021 eternal
celestia one shot
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel comics characters
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]